edificios residenciales en ruinas aquí
en la segunda ciudad ucraniana heart
cliff
[Aplausos]
un tanque puede llegar a corta distancia
y disparar toda su munición sobre zonas
residenciales no le importa dónde y es
imposible saber dónde va a disparar
nuestro juego
aquí no hay nada más que edificios
residenciales es ruedas arriba 33 quien
se conmemora el presidente volodymyr se
lens que dice que las fuerzas ucranianas
están haciendo algunos avances en la
región rescató al señalar que la
situación es difícil en la región de
jarquín pero nuestros militares nuestra
inteligencia tienen importantes éxitos
tácticos la última estrategia de asalto
de moscú lanzada el 18 de abril y
concentrada en el sureste del país va
con retraso avanzando más lentamente de
lo previsto las fuerzas rusas
bombardearon el sábado en la región
oriental del donbass pero no lograron
capturar tres zonas objetivos según los
militares ucranianos mientras tanto en
la asediada ciudad portuaria de mariupol
continúan los bombardeos concentrados en
torno a la planta siderúrgica de asof
tal el último bastión de la resistencia
ucraniana varios centenares de civiles
siguen escondidos bajo tierra la onu ha
estado trabajando para negociar una
evacuación el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de rusia pareció descartar la
necesidad de su participación
no es necesario que nadie preste ayuda
para abrir corredores humanitarios solo
hay un problema los corredores
humanitarios que se anuncian a diario
son ignorados por los ultras nacionales
ucranianos
el alcalde de mariupol ha vuelto a pedir
la evacuación de los civiles dijo que la
planta se está quedando sin alimentos
agua y medicinas